hey everyone so today i'll be talking
about an asymptotically optimal
algorithm for maximum matching and
dynamic streams this is joint work with
separate sadhi at rutgers university
so
what is the matching problem right
so given a graph g
a matching is just a bunch of edges that
don't shed any end points and the
maximum matching then is the matching of
the largest size so the one with the
maximum number of edges so we're given
an example graph here
m over here is a matching of size 2
but there's a larger matching here
m star which is these three blue edges
has a size of 3.
the setting we'll be looking at is the
streaming setting where the information
comes
in a stream
and you can only look at the current bit
of information
and you have to update the memory using
that
and once uh
this information
goes
ahead you are no longer able to access
it
in our context we'll be looking at the
graph streaming setting
where the edges of the graph appear in a
stream and the vertices are fixed from 1
to n
the edges can be inserted or deleted
since it's a dynamic stream
so let's take an example and let's look
at how
this looks
so this edge is inserted
then this one and so on
and then now you see this red edge means
that this is an edge deletion
and this is finally what your graph
looks like
so now what is the
goal of the setting the goal of the
setting is to minimize the amount of
memory and we want to output a solution
at the end of the stream so note that
you don't have to maintain a solution
throughout the stream
okay but unfortunately the matching
problem has a lower bound of n square
and
the trivial solution is just stored the
input stores the entire graph in n
square bits
and so there is no non-trivial solution
and
one when we have such lower bounds we
usually look for approximations
so the question is what about an alpha
approximation right
return a matching m of size at least m
star over alpha where m star is the
maximum matching of the graph can we get
a little of n square space
the trade-off between alpha and the
space is the question we want to answer
so let's look at some previous work that
is
on this problem
conrad 15 gave an upper bound of n
square over alpha square
and a lower bound of n to the 1.5 over
alpha 4.
and you see that the gap over here is
alpha squared times n to the 0.5
asadi atal improved this gap
significantly just to enter the little
of one
the upper bound is n square over alpha
cube
and this o tilde here is uh hiding poly
rock factors
uh and the lower bound is also roughly n
square over alpha cube
chitta satal also gave
the same bound concurrently
and then dark conda 20 gave a lower
bound of n square over alpha cube bits
and now you see that the gap between the
upper and the lower bound is just body
lock bits
right so the best known upper bound is
ortel dense square over alpha q bits and
the best known lower bound
is n square over alpha cube bits
and the gap is polylog n and these gaps
frequently appear in dynamic streams and
the main reason for it
is
the the technique we use to sam uh find
edges in dynamic streams
and this is called l0 sampling
so
the problem is to find just one edge in
a dynamic stream right so you're given
edge insertion then deletions and you
want to just output one edge at the end
and that problem itself is very
non-trivial because what if the edge you
pick is deleted later right and l0
samplers solve this problem
and uh
basically what they do
is they sample an edge uniformly at
random from a set of pairs of vertices
that undergo edge insertions and
deletions
now l0 samplers can be implemented in
log cube and bits of space
but they also need log cuban bits of
space
and many problems in streaming have this
polylog head overhead because of l0
samplers
especially connectivity which has a
lower bound of n lock cube n bits
and this was given by nelson u19
so this rises this raises a question
is this always necessary or is this a
polylog overhead always necessary
now we present our result we we prove an
asymptotically optimal bound or the
space approximation tradeoff
there is a dynamic streaming algorithm
that with high probability gives an
alpha approximation of the maximum
matching
it uses n square over alpha cube bits
and it works for any alpha less than
uh n to the one half
so this as you can see it closes the gap
up to polylog up to constant factors
and also this shows us that polylog
overhead is not always necessary so this
problem the matching problem in
particular doesn't need this overhead
also you might be wondering why we
consider alpha less than n to the one
half
if alpha is greater than n to the one
half then there is not enough space to
output the answer because n over alpha
the number of edges needed is greater
than n squared over alpha cube
so now we show how to prove this
so we first give some simplifying
assumptions for this talk
the input graph is bipartite
the maximum matching has a size omega n
and getting an
theta alpha approximation is enough
and note that all of these assumptions
can be lifted
so now we look at the hard instances
from previous work
conrad 15 asadi atal 16
and dark conduct 20 all of them give
certain versions of uh this hard
instance
so
the top part over here has
little of n over alpha
vertices and the bottom part has theta n
vertices
now if you look at
any any vertex in the bottom part it is
connected to most of the vertices on the
top here these squiggly lines indicate
that um every vertex here is connected
to most vertices here and same for this
quickly line
and if you look at any vertex here and
uh
delete all of the edges it has to the
top part it has just a single edge to
the bottom part
right and the lower bound of dark count
at 20 was n square over alpha cube bits
using this hard instance
so now what is the approach we will be
using to solve our problem right
so we will
first show this lemma called match or
sparsify that either gives a large
matching in which case we're done
or it identifies
a hard instance which is similar to the
hard instances of previous work
and then what do we do we solve this
hard instance
and note that we run both of these
algorithms in parallel
it might uh think that we're saying oh
do my match or specify first and then
solve the hard instances but they're
actually happening in parallel
so what is match or sparsify right so we
find a matching mez in space n square
over alpha cube bits
such that we either get a large matching
of size roughly n over alpha in which
case we're done
or
we get
um
a matching m easy such that when we
delete its vertices or look at the sub
graph induced on its unmatched vertices
we're left with just o tilde n edges
and also
we have
a matching of size omega n within there
so if
so if the matching is large
we're done if the matching is not large
then this remaining graph once you
delete all these nodes has tilde n edges
and a matching of size omega n
so
how do we solve this problem right so we
sample n square over alpha cube times
poly log and random edges note that this
poly organ is in the denominator
and
we do this sampling using l0 samplers
which take polylog n bits
so this will give us a space of n square
over alpha cube bits in total
and then the matching mez is just a
greedy matching over the sampled edges
and we use something which is similar to
a residual property of the greedy
matching
and
it is all right to not know this because
we will not be using it in the talk but
the proof is like along the same lines
but it is considerably different and
interesting to look at look into
we will be skipping it for now because
of time
and we concentrate more on the more
novel parts of our paper
so we look at the similarity
to hard instances of previous work right
so are our heart instances are
qualitatively the same as the hardened
sense of instances of previous work
so this part over here which is the
matching part is similar to this top
part here
once deleted
you get this parse portion over here
which is very similar to this so there
are theta and edges here and there are
other energies here
now we want to solve this hard instance
which is slightly easier to do so first
we will try to solve this one and then
we'll go to the general heart instance
this instance once we apply the analysis
of dark conduct 20 informally
we need n square over alpha cube edges
to be recovered
this itself storing these edges is going
to take n square over alpha cube times
log n bits which is more than our space
budget
and using l0 samplers makes it even
worse makes this log factor into poly
log n
so now we show how to get
rid of this and basically how to solve
the problem when n square over alpha
cube bits
so
now we want to solve this hard instance
so first we use uh match or sparsify
and that
basically gives us this partition of u
and b
of of uh
these vertices which are
which have a very high connection and
these vertices that have just one edge
to p right so this partition we get at
the end of the stream using matrix
parsify
now we look at our input graph
we look at the left side and we try to
group it into groups of size alpha and
we do this partition randomly
then
we
we consider any group uh on the left and
with high enough probability it lies
completely within b
okay so now we focus on one such group
and you see that this group will have
many edges to this red part here
because this is highly connected but it
has only alpha edges to this bottom part
b
and this is because every at every
vertex in this green part will have just
one edge to be
so
our idea is to recover one edge per
group
so
since we just need one edge what we do
is now we subsample with a rate of 1
over alpha so basically for every group
we consider n over alpha
nodes on the right and we call it the
neighborhood of vi
now
the neighborhood of ei will have just n
over alpha nodes
and looking at these
little of n over alpha square come from
u
and the remaining ones come from b
and now this is the one edge we want to
recover so
it has just one edge to the green part
and many edges to the red part and this
is the edge we want to recover
so this actually
uh is
the hard problem we want to solve and
basically the question is can we get
this one neighbor efficiently
and this looks like the set disjointness
problem from communication complexity
right because we want to find a vertex
such that it has an edge from vi
and it is also from the set b
and note that we get the set b at the
end of the stream using match or specify
so
a trivial solution to this problem
is
you can store everything right you store
all the edges of vi so there are little
of n n over alpha square edges to the
red part and one edge here so you can do
it in space n log n over alpha square
bits
but the goal is to do it in n over alpha
square plus log n bits and not times log
n
and the reason for this is uh that this
gives us a space of n square over alpha
cube because the total number of groups
are n over alpha
and this log n is a lower order term
because alpha is much smaller than n to
the one half
good
so what is the idea we represent the
neighborhood vector v i as a binary
vector
and we compute the inner products with
random vectors so you can think of this
as a sketch that we store
and using the sketch we will we will
recover the neighborhood vector
so what is the recovery you go over all
possible neighborhood vectors that could
have been
and check if the inner products match
if for any particular
guess
all the inner products match then that
is the neighbor vector you were looking
for
now the number of possible neighbor
vectors are 2 to the little of n over
alpha square times n
and this is because
for a group here you could have any
subset of u
within the neighborhood so that gives
you 2 to the little of n over alpha
square choices
and then this one edge could be to any
vertex so
it is at most n choices
and this gives you a space of
n over alpha square plus log n bits
exactly what we wanted
however there is an issue here
what we got to know is the name of this
vertex
but we do not know the name of the
endpoint within vi
so we cannot recover this edge we just
recover this end point
so basically we need the grouping on the
right hand side as well to solve this
problem
so you consider the bipartite graph
again
and you group both sides this time
randomly
then looking at any group with high
enough probability it lies completely
within b
so now we focus on one such group
again
we know that
uh for this group we have alpha edges
going to be
but we just need one edge
so
what we will do is we will subsample
again
and this this time for every group
we consider one over alpha fraction of
the groups on the right and call it its
neighborhood
so for any group v i in particular it
has n over alpha square groups in its
neighborhood
so the green groups lie completely
within b and the red groups are a mix of
u and b or either just completely new
and this is the edge we want to recover
note that there might be multiple edges
between v i and v j
but with high constant probability there
is just one edge between v i and v j
so we want to recover this edge now
so the way we do it is we look at the
neighborhood sketch of vi
and find this node
u inside vj
and then we look at the neighborhood
sketch of vj and find this node v inside
vi
and now we know
that since there is just one edge
between them
we get uh this edge and we can recover
it
and now note that we can recover
uh this
such an edge for a constant fraction of
the groups so that gives you a matching
which is of size omega n over alpha
which is enough for us
so now we've solved this problem
but we want to solve a more general
problem right and there are a few
challenges
so if you look at
uh
this graph there are only theta and
edges
in the sparse part
but over here we have o tilde and edges
which is more and the more annoying part
is that we cannot bound the degree of
vertices with a constant
so over here the degree of vertices is
just one
but over here they could be much larger
so some of them could have a super
constant degree and some of them could
have a small degree
so now this gives rise to our sparse
neighborhood recovery sketch
and
this is the general sketch we will use
to solve this problem
so we're given a graph g in a dynamic
stream we're given a set s known before
the stream and a set t known after the
stream
and the goal is to get n of s minus t so
in this picture this is the set s we
know know from the beginning and this is
the set t
we are given at the end and we want to
recover this moon shaped region n of s
minus t
we're also given a few promises that the
size of t is at most a
and the size of this moon shaped region
is at most p n of s minus t is at most p
also any vertex here
has
just a constant number of edges to s
okay
so the trivial solution for this problem
is just store everything again right for
s store all of its uh neighbors
and this will take a log n plus b log n
bits right because this
n of s could be of size
uh order a plus b times log n
uh
a plus b good
but now the goal is to drop this log
factor because we don't really need to
store the edges 2t right because we just
want to recover the edges to nfs so this
this could this is uh seems like a valid
goal to have
so we could use the previous ideas of
inner products but that gives us two
problems one is that
you need exponential time for recovery
and the other problem is that the random
bits needed is much more than the space
budget
so we get rid of these problems
using
sparse recovery ideas
and it's slightly complicated so we
avoid it in this talk
so the space bound is a plus b log n
bits and this is theoretically optimal
right
so now we've shown how to solve these
general hard instances and the main tool
we use the sparse neighborhood recovery
sketches
and the space now is n square over alpha
cube bits
so now we conclude
the first step was match or sparsify
we used n square over alpha cube bits of
space
and we either get a large matching or we
get a hard instance that is sparse and
contains a large matching
our recovery sketches can be used to
solve these hard instances in n square
over alpha cube bits and note that we
run both of these algorithms in parallel
and get the final algorithm
so there is a dynamic streaming
algorithm that with high probability
outputs and alpha approximation to
maximum matching
using n square over alpha cube bits of
space
the lower bound of dark on that 20 is n
square over alpha cube bits making our
algorithm optimal
the polylog and overhead of l0 samplers
is not always necessary unlike nelson
u19
and now these polylog and overheads are
due to the use of l0 samplers and you
can see them everywhere in dynamic
streaming literature so now the question
we pose is that can our techniques be
used to bypass this polylog and barriers
and some problems we can think of a
vertex cover dominating set and vertex
connectivity
this is where i will end and thank you
so much for listening